en fait mais ce rallye je crois que je
suis au top je prends bien guillet ouais
y'a s'appuie elle table de france comme
votre ancien prof de gym à 3 jean marie
bigard les u19 il a fait qu'un soir
aussi en même temps mauges en q3 ouais
mais dans la petite salle mais dans la
petite salle mais ça faut expliquer ça
aux gens ce que moi j'ai pris des coups
de bus des vagins des publicités et
plein de gens devant il soit c'est pour
qui se prend ce mec là non c'est pas
possible de francs si si je le fais donc
c'est la loge près à côté la loge
présidentielle il ya les tapis rouges
bon devant il ya toujours des racailles
de banlieue avec des tuyaux des places
même si on a tous les débris comme au
stade on a tous fait pareil et donc il
ya les toilettes
et puis là moi je joue à gauche et sur
la fiche écrit il reste 250 façon dans
la salle ses 17 18 et 19 mars voilà
alors c'est vrai que le public vous a
connu surtout à la télévision dans le
rôle du journaliste au ringard c'est un
peu votre image de marque mais est ce
que les gens payent pour allez vous voir
est ce que est ce que finalement les
gens vont là où je veux dire de plus en
plus voilà ouais mais mes seins et ouais
ça va ça va bien comme et mais à la fois
c'est très difficile pour parler
sérieusement vis bon c'est très
difficile de passer quand on est formaté
télé moi je suis au format télé mais je
peux être plus formaté que ça passait de
télé à spectacle c'est très très très
grand public est bien quand vous
demandez aux gens pendant votre
spectacle vous dites qui a failli pas
venir il ya 80% des gens qui lèvent la
main oui c'est vrai 80 % des gens ont
failli choisir l'ancien numéro privé je
réponds oui il ya 80% des gens de
l'écurie cité qui en curiosités et les
gens et alors pourquoi ils viennent ils
viennent en général parce que c'est
alors moi c'est très particulier un
certain public
c'est j'ai des demandes qui fait quoi
jeudi qui est de droite qui est de
gauche
c'est essentiellement des femmes bout
vieille j'ai des vieilles aussi ah ouais
ouais d'hygiène il est vrai qu'il est là
j'adore les vieux donjon ya beaucoup de
personnes âgées
il ya beaucoup de femmes beaucoup
beaucoup de femmes beaucoup je sais pas
pourquoi
et c'est beaucoup gauche caviar et ump
voilà ouais ouais
entre les deux on les a donc laissé
tomber me sens au chez jamel sur le
moment où les dubosc et en mille sont
pas trop chez moi c'est marrant mais
c'est bien s'est fâché pourquoi pialat
vous fait faire votre spectacle par le
public vous demander son avis est ce que
le texte vous plaît est ce que la mise
en scène au plat c'était au début parce
qu'au début je savais tellement pas du
tout aller et comment faire un spectacle
que je m'arrêtais gibbons ça ils vous
voient ce sketch et amandine en laisse
tomber et j'en rappelle les 15 3
premières semaines doit trouver un
domaine du petit palais des glaces
on avait toujours un peu les mêmes gens
ce qu ont récupéré des gens à droite à
gauche dans la rue on leur donne à
manger des crêpes qui a dû manger chez
moi donc que les hommes
les gens restent et il y avait une mamie
qui disaient qu'ils disent à une autre
elle disait c'est chiant c'était au
début en maintenant au top et et l'autre
et l'autre
elle lui a répondu aux et de la chance
la semaine dernière c'était pire
voilà 17 12
19 mars au stade de france raphaël
mezrahi